it sounds to me like your parents
turned you into a man by being on a
sailboat i bet that had a lot to do with
how you grew up and becoming a man
because i don't remember my dad teach me
anything
like he didn't teach me how to change
the oil in the car he didn't teach me
you know he just said mow the lawn you
know and that he didn't even have a
freaking
grass catcher so all that dog and
rocks would fly in my face
so i know those yeah yeah so he was
always working so he didn't have time to
you know he wasn't a head of a ceo you
know head of a company ceo
and and be able to buy a big sailboat
and go out but like i think you
did you not learn a lot which helped
kind of create who the man you are now
yeah but i mean i learned that on the
boat because before that my
i never saw my dad never saw my dad wow
he was working for
an american company because uh uh
young and rubicon you know and uh and
uh i never saw him so that's why i think
on the boat i by forces of circumstance
you know being on the boat you learn to
yeah to sail and sailing is is very
arduous it's not
easy it's it's tough you know you can be
in really tough conditions and you have
to learn
very quickly how to steer a boat had a
you know
hoist the sails uh drop anchor
and you get into you know sticky
situations when you're in high seas you
know
and and and stormy seas yeah yeah it's
it's a tough environment but you learn
very very fast and yeah
thanks to my dad's decision i learned
to to be much more
self-reliant or just yes that's one
thing i really learned i was super
self-reliant super
agile i could adapt to any situation
suddenly whereas i never felt that in my
sort of
quote unquote civilian life you know
when i was going to school
and i didn't really i felt i fit in
because i was you know
i i wanted to be an actor so i guess i
was the clown that class clown but
it was really the boat that yeah the
trip on the boat and and discovering new
cultures that that
attorney you're right into the man i am
today yeah
it was a very very formative important
experience for me
yes especially i love that do you feel
like you're
like you you hinted about it you sort of
said in a way that you didn't really
have a relationship with your father at
first and then he
has this life change this idea and you
go in the boat was it like
did you sort of resent your father for a
while he's not around he's not there and
then all of a sudden you get on a boat
and it was a little tumultuous at first
and then it became this relationship it
sounds like a movie
but like was it you know that's a really
interesting question because
it's funny because it's kind of the
opposite it's the opposite and the same
before when i never saw him i did i
idolized the image of my father
you know because he's never there so you
you
and he you always see this you know and
in those days growing up in france you
know
fathers were much more severe and
earnest and
you know he was the he was the the man
of discipline you know and
uh not abusive at all but you know he
was
much more stern i i had a much sterner
image of him and then when we
went on the boat then you're confronted
with being with your parents in a small
space for
24 7. so i admired him
and resented him at the same time
because i saw
there was nothing hidden anymore you
know when my dad
woke up in our house and put on his
beautiful suits and everything i was
like wow look at my dad
and then you are confronted with the
absolute reality of
literally being at the next cabin as
your dad on a boat that is
44 feet long so there was a mixture
of you know you're growing up as a
teenager of resentment and admiration at
the same time